[Music]  mommy everything here are you happy yeah  Teen Mom 2 star Chelsea Houska and  husband Col welcomed their first child  on Wednesday the reality star now she  gave birth to baby number 2  instagramming this black and white photo  holding the newborns hand  Chelsea is already mom to daughter  Aubree the proud parents revealed they  named their baby boy Watson Cole and he  is too cute as he takes a sweet slumber  leading up to their son's arrival  Chelsea kept her followers up to date on  her pregnancy journey sharing sweet  photos of her growing baby bump and  adorable little outfits for the couple's  upcoming bundle of joy congratulations  to the happy couple on their new  addition  you